while you may like how much cheaper it
is to fill up your car some of the
world's largest oil exporters are
freaking out they base their budgets on
the price of oil and that price has more
than halved since June so how much did
the biggest losers think they were going
to get per barrel to run their countries
Russia budgeted for a hundred and five
dollars per barrel now its economy is in
meltdown thanks in part to sanctions by
the west Venezuela budgeted for a
hundred and seventeen dollars per barrel
there's serious social unrest in the
country and its inflation rate is one of
the world's highest Nigeria budgeted for
a hundred and twenty-two dollars per
barrel it's Africa's largest economy but
oil makes up the bulk of its revenue and
Iran budgeted for a hundred and
thirty-five dollars per barrel but
sanctions over its nuclear program
already keep it from selling 1 million
barrels a day what is fracking it's
short for hydraulic fracturing it's
different from the traditional way of
getting at oil and gas reserves first a
well is drilled to reach